live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create real
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast on
ramsey networks is my co-host today as
we answer your questions about your life
and your money it is a free call and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five mary in tallahassee florida
starts off this hour hey mary what's up
hi how are you thank you for taking my
call my pleasure how can we help honor
it's an honor to speak with you you too
what's up
well i have a question i
have an
inheritance and
my sister was left out of the will
whoa why
i think that there's been some conflict
along the years that i don't think that
got resolved
one was
her significant other
and
it just never got resolved and some
things had been
said along the way my mom was very
strong strong-willed and very
independent my dad passed away 25 years
ago so she had to be that so your mom
was not in relationship with your sister
and chose to not leave her anything as a
result
exactly well that sounds reasonable
oh wow okay
well why would your mom leave something
to somebody that doesn't speak to her
yeah well she tried to
my sister tried to with my mom but my
mom had just had
enough
right she'd had enough she cut her off
right in life and death
right
you know you know the old-fashioned
saying for that is you're dead to me you
ever heard that
yes yeah sometimes teenagers usually
they don't know what they're talking
about but that's where it comes from
so mary do you feel guilty is that why
you're calling
at first i did but then i kind of got
i got shut down basically she
she said are you going to you know split
this with me just i want to know so if
you're not that means you agree with
with
mom i said i didn't say that we're not
taking that guilt trip no thank you
that's on her yeah i kind of i kind of
with your mom i don't like your sister
much
[Laughter]
well so it has been yes because i'm
trying trying to do the main thing but
also at the same time i'm trying to
honor my mom
and i tried to smooth things over and it
it did not work i tried my very best
and now i was your sister's a head case
yeah
so i've you know i was like well what do
i do now so it's been uh it
you meet you lose your parents you know
to dementia alzheimer's and then you
deal on this and now
not talking to me so i'm like well where
do i go because that's going to cut that
that's going to cut that no no no no no
no no no no no no no
you not giving her money is not cutting
the relationship off she is choosing
to cut the relationship off
oh
that makes sense you didn't choose she
chose i'm sorry it hurts though yeah it
does and when when you have a
manipulator trying to manipulate you and
you don't fall for it and they they back
off and throw grenades it does hurt i'm
so sorry what was your relationship to
your sister prior to the inheritance
well
i've always wanted more of a
relationship
than what i got and uh now when there's
money she wants a relationship
uh yeah but there's you have to buy a
relationship isn't that called
prostitution
yeah
right
but also at the same time i don't know i
think that there was a lot of uh what do
you call it uh resentment towards me
which i did not know it finally came out
when my mom got sick seven years ago
with them with uh alzheimer's dementia
and it all came out and i'm like what
did i you know what did i do and then
this is the fine final thing you're
gonna have to release yourself the truth
is did you really do anything but wrong
mary no you did were you mean to your
sister no did you reach out to her yes
did she reciprocate no
did she call you up after there was
money involved yes only when there was
money involved did she actually reach
out and act like you
needed a relationship with her
right
she did not that's right
she's not really interested in a
relationship with you she's just
interested in money is that wrong am i
wrong
you're spot on that's what the evidence
in this discussion says anyway
but it still hurts
yes because it's your sister it's your
last remaining relative now with your
dad and your mom both gone you've you
know you feel it feels she puts it on
you as if you caused this you didn't
cause any of it
she chose to be resentful to you
because you were actually able to
maintain a relationship with your mother
albeit your mother might be difficult
too it sounded like but you were able to
maintain that
and you weren't being manipulative in
that you were just able to walk a road
your sister couldn't walk with your mom
and so now she's mad at mom and now
she's mad at you and now if you don't
give her money she's mad at you
right
right and i also was told
uh my mom
destroyed our family
by doing that so i was that was
and then i said
mom loved her family don't
don't ever tell me that she left her
family so it was it kind of had built
from there yeah well she's hurt and mad
at you right
right she's a wounded wounded girl but
um
if i thought you giving her money would
make all of this go away and everybody
would be happy and not not weird and you
guys would just be great little sisters
like in some movie or something
yeah i would tell her to share it with
her because it's just stupid money
but money's not the problem here it's
just it's just revealing the problem
right
and so it doesn't we know it's not going
to fix it because let me tell you give
her half the money okay how long is it
set your watch how long is it for she's
pissed off about something else
true tick tick tick tick oh there it is
yeah
true so that tells us it's not about the
money
it's about the dysfunctional sister so
um
you know uh uh
you know what i would just say
you you know dr john baloney would say
write her a letter
and then maybe don't send it just get it
out of your system but grieve
the loss of the relationship because it
hurts
and you know you might just set some
boundaries and tell her listen this is
not about money when you and i are
friends again we can talk about stuff
like money but right now i've tried to
have a relationship with you and you
didn't want to have one until there was
money involved so
it's this is on you
you know and so if you want to come hang
out for a dinner anytime i'd love to
have you i'm not mad at you but as of
right now uh no we're not gonna have any
financial discussions or transactions
you know if you ever need any help and
and we're in a good strong relationship
together again i'll try to help you
but so the other thing i try to remember
is okay i get that mom wasn't the
easiest person but you know this is her
will it's what she wanted to happen
that's why they call it a will this is
what i will to happen i want this to
happen
and that was her will she decided with
her money what she wanted to have
happened to her money
it's not your place to change that
and so i wouldn't especially in this
situation because it's not going to get
you what you want
but it does hurt
and i'm sorry
before little sister she's messing up
this is the ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple h
825. five
two two five
okay rule of thumb
uh everybody needs a will
go to
mamabearlegalforms.com get your will put
ramsey in the promo and you'll find the
deals right everybody ought to have a
will
if you have a whacked family situation
like our last caller
where someone's not going to be in the
will or they're you're getting
different levels
of inheritance for whatever reason
um or it's complicated like you've got a
blended family yours mine and ours
that kind of thing
um
the
you owe it to
your family
to have a reading of the will
before you die
hard to do it after yeah well there's a
reading but not you doing it so yeah you
need to sit down tell everybody why
what's happening
is happening
and
that's the deal because it can ruin
relationships as we saw with the last
caller exactly it no that relationship
was already ruined there wasn't one
there it exposed a ruined relationship
but it didn't cause it but the thing is
what that mom did by not telling the
sister that she was cutting her out
she leaves the pressure on the remaining
sister
and the the anger directed at mom gets
transferred to her sister
so you just say
uh
you're not getting as much
you know for whatever reason and you
explain it to them and then if they want
to not like it they cannot like it while
you're alive
that's called
character courage
those kinds of things now in this case
mom had dementia and in this case she
didn't have enough of a relationship to
even have the discussion with the little
sister it sounds like so i'm not sure
she did anything wrong in that regard
but
we go to great lengths inside the ramsey
family
to make sure that everyone knows where
they stand
no surprises
this is who's in the will this is what's
going on this is what the whale looks
like this is what that trust is going to
do this is what's going to happen with
that piece of real estate this is what's
going to happen with the company this is
what's going to happen with that
and it's so bad
that we have a
annual estate planning meeting where we
discuss my death in front of me is there
a name for that yeah it's the if dave
dies this year meeting
so um it's awful it's like a monty
python movie you know i'm feeling much
better it's just a flesh wound but oh my
god you know i'm planning my death every
year it's morbid as crud well and the
sooner the older you get the you know
the more
i'm just saying you're worse
yeah no it's uh the closer you are you
got one foot in the grave come on dave
you need to be doing this but yeah it's
you don't have to do it every year in
our case it's so much going on it's so
complicated there's so many moving parts
that we even bring in our leadership
team here at ramsey so that they know
the operating board they know what's
going to happen who's doing what and we
don't get into the infinite details but
the all the stuff concerning those
people if it concerns you you should be
in there
you know
and so
take the time and then you don't have
this dramatic reading of the will with
all the emotions like some murder agatha
christie movie thing
or something uh with the ridiculous uh
plastic surgery stepmother and the
lost uh lost child coming in from
nowhere and ridiculous things family
members coming out of the woodwork i
remember when richard pryor was the toy
remember that was a thousand years ago
movie so but those are bizarre human or
bizarre movie scripts they should not
happen in real life
okay you should it should be a um
you know
people should say this is where it is
and and i'm perfectly okay if you don't
want to give someone your money because
by the way it's your money
you get to decide that
i if if i think it's weird i'll tell you
but if the girl hasn't spoken to her
mother for years
and her mother doesn't leave her money
that would seem logical to me
but she thinks
owed money just because you're in the
dna chat yeah there's an entitlement
there yeah the dna chain does not mean
you're owed money now the law will give
you money if there's not a will but
morally you are not owed money because
you're in the dna chain
just you know so if you're meaner than
crud to your whole family and everybody
in the family hates you and your mean
boyfriend is mean to your mean mother
there's a lot of mean people in here
then your mean mother doesn't leave you
and your mean boyfriend money why would
you be shocked
it sounds logical
you know but me and mom ought to go
ahead and tell mean daughter
you know you're mean and i'm mean and
i'm not leaving you any of my mean money
do people just not want to have that
uncomfortable conversation is that why
they don't do this
they're they're cowards
and so have the courage to call it and
say this is what's going on
you know you vote the wrong way i'm not
leaving you any money i'm not supporting
that party you know
you you don't know how to vote for
presidents so i'm not going to help you
i mean i don't care what it is you get
to decide it's your money you can be as
crazy as weird as you want to be with
your money that's the plan
so that's what we're doing get a will
and talk about the will get a will and
tell everybody what's in it that you
know
i know people that do a will leave
someone to be the guardian of their
children and didn't bother to check with
them oh boy
it's like surprise just got three kids
can you do that legally do they legally
do that legally but it'd be a it's i'd
just cause anything like that i don't
want to talk doing a wheel was hard
enough i don't want to talk about what's
in it and i don't care you need it's
like grown-up stuff boys and girls
jill's with us in los angeles hey jill
what's up
hi sarah thank you for taking my call
sure
how can we help
so i am 19 years old and i would like
your advice on what to do with some
extra savings i have
cool
how'd you get the money
okay so i have four accounts right now
so i work a part-time job at an ice rink
i'm a i'm an assistant coach and uh from
that job i have built fifteen hundred
dollars in a checking account and ninety
five hundred dollars in a stainless
account way to go
thank you that's awesome and then uh
separately i have about forty seven
thousand dollars in my dad's credit
union
and then i have an investment account
with roughly a hundred thousand dollars
in an s p 500 index fund whoa where'd
you get that
uh my grandmother she is uh she's very
blessed and she's very generous
wow good for you and the 47k the credit
union where'd that come from
also my grandmother okay cool and it's
all in your name
yes i can't touch it until i want to buy
a house or a car but that's not going to
be an issue right now since i have a car
already my parents are on baby step
seven
why can't you touch it you promised you
wouldn't
yes um i wanna i wanna save it and uh no
i i don't think i don't say it's unwise
uh you said i can't
but i think you meant i won't
yeah i won't okay you don't it's not in
a trust it's not a legal document but
you just promised grandma you wouldn't
use it except for those things
correct good okay that's a good promise
okay good what's the horizon look like
as far as college do you plan on going
to college
yes so currently i'm a sophomore in
college and i'm studying to be a
dietitian cool is school paid for or are
you cash flowing it
completely paid for my parents fully
funded it and my grandmother pitched
into wow you've got some awesome family
who have a good head on their shoulders
oh i am extremely blessed so your
question is what
um so
should i keep my 9 500 in my savings
account or should i invest that money so
it can grow
do you have an emergency fund currently
uh yes my checking account is that part
of the 47k
no it's uh part of the checking account
with the 1500 in it that doesn't sound
like much of an emergency fund yeah your
9 500 your emergency fund so no
no i would just leave it sitting there
where are you living right now are you
renting are you with family
i'm living for my parents and i'm
commuting out to college currently okay
cool well let's let's get through school
let's see what life looks like on the
other side and then we can decide what
to do with this money but you've got a
car school's paid for the next logical
goal would be to get that down payment
on the house when you're ready for it
but there's no rush you're doing great
at 19
after your next logical goal is finish
school yes and you got that seam to have
that covered but i'm just going to let
the 9500 sit there it's just a nice
little insurance policy it's not really
going to make you rich or make you poor
what you do with it it's not enough
money to do that so
a lot of these other things the habits
you're learning the things you're
gleaning from your family how smart
they've been
that's all setting you up and you really
do have a great
eye on this and a great intentionality
that's more important than the 9500 i
would let it sit there as your emergency
fund
thanks for the call
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage jason
and allison are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave how's it going welcome
welcome where do you guys live
we're from raleigh north carolina cool
welcome to nashville and here we do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off we paid off 240 000
good for you how long did that take took
a little over eleven years eleven years
four months oh okay very good and your
range of income during that time we
started out around fifty thousand single
income and it got up to 150 000. wow
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a teacher
and i'm a
replacement manager for a hvac company
okay cool very cool good for you
so 240 000 over 11 years is that your
house that is our house all right
look at the weird people
man no house payment how old are you two
39 and 40. wow in a paid for
house yes what's the house worth we
checked this morning it was 457 000
let's go
i love it how much in your retirement
accounts we have a little over 200 000
we just kind of
got that going back yeah here in the
last couple of years um so that's that's
our next goal to get that knocked out
yeah you're getting ready to be baby
steps millionaires look at you guys 40
years old you're right on track well
done
that's a long
track man 11 years and four months tell
us the story what got that started
well we we started when we found out um
i was pregnant with our daughter and
we decided that i should stay home for a
little while we had our son turned two
right after she was born so
two basically two and under was a bit of
a challenge and
so i stayed home for four years and
that's when we started looking towards
the baby steps and the envelope system
and
um i was able to stay home for four
years and then once i went back to work
things really got into motion for us
but we took after two years of staying
home we took fpu
and that really set us on um like you
said like you say with
the gazelle we were ready to go we got
rid of cable and we took away some other
things and
um
just once i went back to work things
really got into gear for us wow and you
met dave i just saw a photo it looks
vintage check this out was it news radio
680
oh that's over there yeah okay look at
that that's a ways back there so is that
along the journey you guys
met him there he was actually he came to
raleigh for entre leadership book you
just come out with it and uh
i was like come on alison grab the kids
we got to get up there you got to meet
this guy and he's going to change our
life and he did wow that's impressive
wow so proud of you guys was this all
the mortgage the 240 did you guys have
any other type of debt along the way a
majority of it was um
we had part of a car in there and an atv
but majority of it we we cleared that
out real quick soon as we got on but we
were like no it mean more into our kids
if they could be here
with us when we fully pay everything off
and
we we didn't we didn't call her anything
we were like nope
we're going to continue till we get to
the final stage and we can do it in
practice yep dude everything so now our
kids are you know a little bit more
grown compared to those pitchers and now
we're hoping that it sinks in a little
bit more and
they get a lot from it that's fun
very fun and that's a long time to stick
with it as we said uh what do you think
the key is to sticking with it into
getting out of debt
i would say as far as
staying on the same page having budget
meetings you know we get to the end of
the month and
they're getting started and then we
would even throughout the process we
would run out of money before month but
we stuck with it i did a lot of side
work i've been in heat and air ever
since i was
you know right out of high school so i
knew how to do
work on the side and make some extra
money you know i wasn't around all the
time but now that we're here that time
that i missed
being out on the weekends and late at
night running service calls and all that
good stuff it's worth it now because
it's it's pay help us dig out of that
hole a lot faster to where now i don't
do that anymore i'm here at home when
the you know wife and family and spend a
lot more time and it was worth it at
that time to be that godzilla intense
yeah and pressing through it wow and one
thing too we we always went up on a
vacation um that was one thing that we
didn't give up
um just which you're not supposed to and
baby steps four five six you're supposed
to go on vacation but a lot of people
you know say well we're not going to do
this we still wanted to have those
experiences with our kids and
make those memories so that was another
thing that we still made paying off your
house in 11 years that's the normal i
mean that's about the right track i mean
that's the
anywhere from 7 to 14 is our is our
range and most people hit it around 10
or 11 years so these are some of the
things that we cash flowed uh two trips
to disney um we went to paris and london
just her and i
um for 10 days we took the kids camping
out west twice to grand canyon
and yellowstone
um both of them embraces we cashflowed
every bit of that
and um
my wife had a wrist surgery and we paid
for a new car with new to us used car
and we also got a camper in that process
and every bit was paid by cash
wow that's exactly how you're supposed
to do it perfectly done well done you
guys
no trauma for the kids they're not
scarred they had a great childhood
america if you're wondering you guys are
incredible reminder gazelle intensity is
baby steps one through three which is
getting out of debt everything but the
house and getting the emergency fund and
then when you move from that to baby
steps 456 which is where they've been
the majority of this 11 years while all
these things happened uh you're moved
from intensity to intentionality so you
guys work that plan perfectly
exactly what you're supposed to do very
very well done excellent excellent job
how does it feel now that you don't have
a payment in the world
[Music]
really good
we got out in the front yard we walked
in the grass barefooted
we heard everybody else on the range
shows like we got to try this and we did
it and it was awesome
what the neighbors think are they going
there's some weird people in there
we did it in daylight so
walking around with a mortgage on fire
in your hands
have you had a few paychecks hit without
the mortgage now yeah where it stays
with you we paid it off in february oh
awesome
it's it's
the
muscle memory of paying that payment now
we don't have it now it's like you gave
yourself a raise we did well we disney
world in june it was like
not nearly as stressful i mean we
weren't going crazy or anything but we
could i felt like we could enjoy it you
know
yeah you're gonna think about the money
yeah yeah i used to know a guy he said
my goal is make enough money where i can
read the menu from left to right
i love that it says start instead of
starting with the price right and we'll
just order what i want and then let me
look at the price absolutely that's
that's what you did at disney you know
you didn't you weren't out of control
you weren't out of control but you just
you could just do it and it was going to
be okay
it's not it's not the way to go you guys
you're exactly living like no one else
so later you can live and give like no
one else beautifully done beautifully
done well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you without a doubt
that's the next chapter in your story
and total money makeover for you to give
away and get someone else started
financial peace university membership
for a year thanks to brand new videos
with george and dr john delony and
rachel cruz and me and them it's the
best videos we've ever done in that
class by the way right now those of you
that need to go back through fpu some of
you that's uh it's a good time to do it
so well done and you brought the kiddos
bring them up what are their names and
ages
jacob is 13 and katherine is 11. and
they were just little babies when all
this starts huh yeah they were
now he's a two-year-old and a bait and a
brand new baby yeah yeah wow very very
cool do they learn some things along the
way some money principles he actually
already has a few of the books
yeah financial peace baby right here i
love it and he gets to listen to the
podcast with me in the car most times
whenever we're driving somewhere that's
too dave he has the opportunity to
listen i love that
not has to guess
this is a great well done you guys great
looking family i'm so proud of y'all
you're heroes thank you very very well
done you own your life
jason and allison jacob and catherine
raleigh north carolina 240 000 paid off
housing everything
11 years and four months making 50 to
150 count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream all right here we go three two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
i
love it
another family tree change just like
that before our eyes boom just like that
man that's a cool family this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here every time you hear
someone do their debt-free scream and
you know at some point they said i've
had enough i'm not living like this
anymore i've had it
when you get mad like that
and you're ready to change that's when
you that's when you really will change
until until then it's an intellectual
discussion and intellectual discussions
never moved anybody off the center
wrong you gotta decide to control what
you can control and step into it your
behavior you gotta deal with the
behavior
the problem with your money the problem
with my money is the guy in my mirror
financial peace university will show you
how to get control and change your
future
it'll show you every detail of the
step-by-step plan everything you should
have been taught with money
and about money but weren't nearly 10
million people have gone through this
learning how to get out of debt be on a
budget work with their spouse build
wealth increase their generosity
yeah don't let debt and money stress
control your life finally say it
enough take back control of your life
financial peace university ramsey
solutions dot com slash enough
ramsey solutions dot com slash
enough
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five lacey is in denver hi
lacey how are you
good thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help
i have a question about baby step five
um
my husband and i are out of debt we have
a
an emergency fund
we are rather behind in retirement
um and we have we have six children four
are adults
and they
um are in or have finished college all
on their own they got ins they got a
scholarship they had part-time jobs
internships
on their own debt-free
either have finished or are in process
of that
we also have two younger children who
are only in third and fourth grade and
our income has
increased dramatically
so for the first time i feel like we
really have the ability to actually save
for college for them
but we're kind of debating whether or
not we even want to do that
because it's been so good for our older
children um
we're not i don't know it's ethical to
just say we can but we're not going to
pay for college sure
it's ethical
definitely ethical
it would also not be unethical to just
pay for college
okay
i mean unless you raise some entitled
brat i think paying for college you know
they're it's not going to change their
character whether they pay now you want
them to have some skin in the game
that's what i'm hearing
yeah i do you treat college differently
are you worried about what the four
older ones will think
a little bit
yeah
well i mean it's it's okay to have an
awkward discussion with the four older
ones in the room one time but like like
at christmas go hey guys we need to have
15 minutes awkward everybody hold your
breath you ready
here we go
fair is where the tilt-a-whirl is and
they have cotton candy so let's talk
about fair
how would you feel
because now we make more money than
we've ever made before
if we were to actually financially help
your little brother and little sister
where we didn't help you how would y'all
feel about that let's just talk about it
by the way you don't really get a vote
we're just asking for your opinion
and have an awkward conversation and get
that out of the way i'll tell you what
you might learn you might learn that
they say this was the best thing that
ever happened to me and you go you know
what i i don't i really don't want to
steal that from the little ones i'm
going to make them work their butts off
too or they might go you know it was
okay we got through it but it kind of
left some scars and i love my little
brother and sister enough if you pay for
part of it it'd make me happy
they might
say either one one of them might say one
thing the other one might say the other
is that right
you just had pictures you just had
pictures of their faces flash in front
of your mind that one's going to say
that no one's going to say that you just
did just now i watched you do it
i think you're seeing it with black and
white options of a or b why not have the
money there and have parameters around
it and say hey we have 30 grand per
years per year you can go to the state
school if anything beyond that you pay
for and you're going to get a part-time
job and still apply for scholarships but
our kids have had some fun adult
discussions the oldest is a daughter the
middle is a daughter and my youngest is
my son and they've had some fun
discussions in our presence
where denise is like you know i i
couldn't do one tenth of the things you
got away with little brother
you know because they were hardcore
and then you know and and so
and you know what they all survived and
they don't like each other less and they
don't like us less because of it there
was no malice involved but by the time
we got to the third one by the time you
get to the sixth one you know some of
your energy runs out and you're just
like oh whatever jump off a cliff
whatever you're gonna do go go play with
a lawnmower it's okay i mean you know
whatever it is you're gonna yeah
whatever you're just a little bit less
freaked out the first one you're like oh
god they're near the kitchen you know
it's like and so you just
and and you're much we were harder on
our oldest discipline wise
and i think we got lazy or we started
figuring out it wasn't all necessary or
whatever i mean we weren't like super
hard on one and not hard on the other
one oh they all had to behave but you
know i i hey fair is where the tilt war
and the cotton candy is i mean it's you
don't get fair
so i think you're doing okay either way
it's just i probably really good family
exercise to have a fun
over thanksgiving discussion instead of
getting out john delony's conversation
cards use these use this right and so
the key is to have a conversation and
have some fun with it and laugh about it
and because listen you make a lot more
money your life is different than it was
when those kids were this when your
oldest one was in third grade
you have a you're different people your
different life you make a lot more money
it's a different situation you go on
better vacations now
um you go out to eat at better places
now
uh and those kids get to ride along and
the older one didn't and so that's how
life work it's okay it's it's all right
you're not a bad person either way yeah
it's not unethical ethics are not on the
table here um
but i know a lot of people that are
hardcore and say yup not paying for any
of it it's good for them just gutted out
i'm going to coach you i'll be your
biggest cheerleader but you get nada
you're going to figure this out i'll
show you what to do but i'm not signing
any loans and i'm not giving any money
so here's what you do you need to get
some scholarships a job and go to school
you can afford and they start laying it
out ahead of time and puts the
perimeters and you know like you did
with your oldest ones and you could do
that there's nothing wrong with that
there's also nothing wrong with paying
for college
ethically yeah i don't think it's going
to create a bunch of brats i think what
she's wanting is the character that it
created to have them
at scholarships and part-time jobs it's
good and uh
just to position that while we're having
a discussion and not really part of her
answer but just all three ramsey kids we
paid for the college but there were
parameters
lots of parameters parameters are you're
going to live on the budget and here's
the amount you have to live on it's not
it's not opulent
um and um
you're gonna uh you're gonna be walking
a values-based life that aligns with our
family value system
uh which we're christians so that would
include welcome of god
and so you're not going to be off
misbehaving uh going bananas out there
okay and and us writing checks for your
misbehavior we're gonna fund your
misbehavior not likely not gonna happen
so uh you know you're gonna you know
gonna be doing that and when
and they had to finish in four years is
that right yeah they had to finish for
four years and they went to an in-state
school and uh so we weren't wasting
money
and so um so if rachel said dave i want
to go to a private school
in a different state i'm not paying for
it you actually she paid for she did no
no it's worse than that she wanted to go
to an out of state university in the sec
that was not the university of tennessee
which is somewhat like blaspheming but
yeah i know
yeah we just shut that heretic down
right quick
because it was uh i mean it was like 3
000 bucks or something at that time to
go to ut
and it was like 14 000 to go to this
other sec school which will not be named
which will not be named um but the only
reason she wanted to do it was she
thought it was cool
it had nothing to do with nothing and
then i was at 17 11 000
because you went across the state line
and got basically the same education i
don't think so at 17 you're not doing
math you're just picking the coolest
option that's it well rachel it would
just be i wanted to be different
i don't want to be like everyone else
well she's accomplished that yeah she
has accomplished that and made a brand
out of it it's pretty good i'm proud of
her
good stuff it's a good discussion this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is done cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status simple choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five
two two five aaron is with us in austin
texas hi aaron how are you
hi dad hi george uh how y'all doing
today great man what's up
so i've got a question about selling
my house
um
i'm just taking on a promotion and so
i'll be selling within the next 30 days
and i listen to you religiously so
i kind of know your answer but i want to
make sure
um
instead of using a real estate agent
i was thinking about selling it myself
and using my brother-in-law who's an
attorney
to do all the paperwork to save in the
realtor cost
i did speak to a real estate agent
that sold us the house back in 2018 and
based on the comps right now she had
told me about a month ago that she felt
very comfortable listing the house at
least 2 30.
or i'm sorry 3 30. and so i was wanting
to go a little over that
and um i'm looking at maybe 20 000 and
the fees so i just he he would be doing
it for free my brother-in-law so i just
wanted to get your thoughts on that
okay your brother-in-law's not doing
anything that the real estate agent does
when you sell a house you typically use
a title company or a closing attorney to
close the house
and you pay a closing fee and the
closing fee is not that much money
so you're not really saving anything
that's a real estate agent the real
estate agent doesn't close the house
anyway they just are the marketing
agent
and they sell the house for you help you
with the negotiation help you walk
through the whole
sale process and all the details but
when you finally get to closing is the
only time that you're using an attorney
you don't use an attorney to draft a
sales contract on a residential property
the sales contract's just written
just written up by an agent but what
about the profits though
the profits from the from the sell of
the houses don't they get like a six
percent on the profit to sell the house
no they get six percent usually of the
uh sale price of the house
and there's lots of research out there
that shows that you will get on average
more than six percent
for the house because you used a
professional agent that knows what
they're doing and um and so the typical
house sold through a typical
good high quality realtor sells for more
than six percent more
than the typical fsbo for sale by owner
like you're talking about doing because
you don't know what the flip you're
doing
i mean you already stumbled around your
pricing just in describing it to us
so aaron let's walk through this if you
do a for sale biometer let's say you're
able to sell for 300 because you can't
do any marketing and you're hoping
someone drives by whatever it is if you
get a good real estate agent you can
clean it up stage it well professional
photos mls listing the whole nine yards
you might sell for 335 which means you
made 35 more on that sales price than if
you did selling it on your own and let
me tell you here's what's interesting
let's pretend with this for a second
okay
let's pretend that there was a house
next door to you
that was the same price with the same
features for sale with a real estate
agent
and your house is for sale by owner
with the same price as the real estate
agent house next door okay
which is the way that you would pocket
the commission right you'd have to sell
it for the same amount correct
right and you put six percent in your
pocket if you didn't use a real estate
agent in that scenario
and if that buyer looks at these two
houses that are identical basically or
they're on the same street or they're
next door to each other they've got
basically the same features and the same
price
and he comes and knocks on your door
instead of knocking on the other door
you got to know what he's thinking
hey
i'll be able to get this house cheaper
because this guy's not having to pay a
commission
wouldn't he
yeah
and guess what you can't save the
commission as the seller and the buyer
get a cheaper price save on the
commission as the buyer
both
it's the same commission you both can't
save it
and so it doesn't end up happening is
what happens and so it ends and your
time on the market is longer you're more
prone to make mistakes with the
valuation and what you put it on the
market for the mistakes and negotiation
are horrendous the things you leave out
of the sale contract that cost you a
deal because you don't know what you're
doing
this is your this is a your largest
asset
all you're hiring when you're hiring a
good real estate agent is a consultant
that knows what they're doing now i
don't want you to hire a bonehead real
estate agent that got their license
that doesn't know what they're doing and
doesn't sell any houses that's sweet if
you got your license on selling houses
but you're not really a real estate
agent okay the people that sell you know
40 50 100 houses a year that's a
consultant that knows what they're doing
they're they're worth their money
they're high octane
high
protein and that's how you get after it
and so um
you know just just no i i would use a
good real estate agent i've had a real
estate license since i was
you know since i was 18 years old 1978
and um
it's not unusual well i actually own a
real estate company too now but as an
internal as part of our property
management process so i use them but
they are real estate agents too they
know what they're doing
to sell a property for us we don't sell
many properties hardly at all but uh
when i listed my personal residence
and i sold it last year in 2020 i listed
it with a real estate agent again i
full disclosure owned the company but
um i didn't keep the commission i paid
the agent the commission
that works here worked for me you know
so
uh and i know what the flip i'm doing
but i also know enough to know that i
don't know
i'm not up on every little thing that's
going on out there right now because i'm
not doing deals every day i don't do 100
transactions a year personally yeah so i
want somebody that does if they're going
to help me with the marketing of a high
dollar asset get a real estate agent and
go to and don't necessarily go back to
your old agent your old agent might be
fine but go to ramseysolutions.com click
on elp get one of our trusted people
that has a high octane high protein
track record interview three or four
people
if you were gonna hire somebody and pay
them 20 grand
which you are or 10 grand or which you
are
you know you you would
interview more than one
you know that you're not getting a
haircut you're selling your house that's
right this is a big biggest transaction
of your life probably so this is not
amateur hour i don't i don't trust
myself to do it and i've got a pretty
fancy camera and i feel like i've been
in the marketing world but this is
another ball game and i just hired an
electrician could i have youtubed it for
hours and probably got it wrong got in a
fight with my wife got electrocuted all
to save on the electrician's fee
absolutely but i decided uh i'm going to
let the pros do it and that's how i feel
about i don't pull my own teeth yeah
i like to see you try dave got a dentist
just tie it to the doorknob just grab
that piece of paper
needle nose pliers and have at it
i don't even work on my own cars anymore
which is harder for me than the real
estate thing but i i open the hood i
can't even find the yeah i can't find
nothing when i open my car dave it's
just trunk space
you mean you can't find the battery nope
there's a big old battery under there
somewhere it's underneath oh just follow
the smell you'll find it right next to
the fire oh boy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america how many times have you found
yourself saying one day
when thinking about a goal you have one
day i'll be able to buy a house one day
i'll be happy in my career or one day i
won't have to battle with anxiety
anymore stop waiting around whatever
your one day is you got to start right
now
that's why we created smart conference
smart conference is the
one day event
get it where we tackle all areas of your
life and guys let's face it we could use
that kind of boost right now you'll hear
from the nation's top thought leaders
best-selling authors on money career
mental health relationships marriage and
leadership the event will be in dallas
texas on saturday october 22nd event
passes are selling fast to the vip and
platinum is already gone uh you can get
generally general access pass is still
for 39
best-selling authors world-class
speakers include rachel cruz dr john
dolone ken coleman george campbell
christina ellis i'll be there and our
friends and leadership experts from life
church teaching on marriage craig and
amy grochelle and of course we have some
big surprises planned too listen this is
already 65 sold out and it's in october
so i'm telling you most of our events
are selling out way early right now if
you want to come i would suggest you go
and get your tickets and if y'all if you
come i will make you this promise it's a
day long i will also promise you'll
leave tired and emotional and you will
be smarter that's why we call it smart
conference
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from rick in
rhode island i see many multi-family
real estate investment groups on
linkedin and other platforms many
require a minimum investment of thirty
five thousand dollars it's my
understanding this investment is to grow
capital needed to construct or purchase
apartment complexes or condo type
housing the payouts come at a
predetermined point in the future what
are your thoughts on investing with
these groups and how risky is this type
of investment
in general there's a huge spectrum
of risk
to give you a general answer all the way
from your craziest crud never do it to
probably very little risk it's probably
a good solid deal
so the the trick would be
how do you alleviate that risk you've
got to do a lot of due diligence on
the actual people doing the offering
okay
some of these are structured as what are
called limited partnerships you would be
an lp a limited partner the general
partner is in control
100
the amount of fees that they charge for
putting the deal together front end back
end
going in going out handling the
renovations whatever it is they're going
to do the property management all that
kind of thing
the fees that they have they charge can
be the place that you lose your shirt
where you you know you make almost no
money you put 35 000 and you get 37 000
out three years later and that would be
like a waste of time for the risk you
took you could have just about made that
in a stupid bank account right
so um
they can be
very risky if the general partner
doesn't know what they're doing or if
they load it with fees
but there are many of them that are
operating that do a great job
uh and you know i've got
i don't do this kind of thing because i
only buy i don't do partnerships
uh the only ship they won't sale is a
partnership so i don't get in
partnerships and i for sure don't get in
partnerships where i have zero control
uh someone else is controlling my
destiny you're just hoping it'll just
hope at all
out of me so i don't do this kind of
thing but i've got several wealthy
friends that have that do these things
you know 35 to 150 000 bucks a pop and
they put money in and they're making
good rates of return with proven track
record
general partners or however structured
the operator is the trick
and whoever's operating the deal
and of course you know the market what
happens with multi-family is it has it
peaked out and then it's going to be
five years before it makes any money i
don't know i have no idea and we don't
know rick's financial situation but who
is this right for i mean
people that have 35 000 to burn
you're 100 debt free housing everything
you probably got a million dollar plus
net worth
uh
you your retirement is more than covered
and you're continually putting that in
uh
you certainly don't have any debt at all
i already mentioned that once
uh but this is this is high net worth
people that are debt free and make a lot
of money and 35 000 is money they could
lose at the roulette table and wouldn't
miss it
that's the only way you should put it in
it's not an appropriate investment for
someone other than that and it's not a
get-rich-quick scheme no no
but if you're looking to make a budget
again is it 100
um
invalid no not if you're not if you're
sitting in some cash and you want to
play you want to play with some of that
cash but check these people out because
the spectrum of
it goes all the way from awesome to
sucks i mean it's
and not only the deals but the people
running the deals and their level of
integrity their level of expertise their
level of competence all of that and the
same thing goes for those uh the real
estate investment trusts which is kind
of like investing they're a little bit
easier to check and a little bit more
buttoned up on how they're structured
it's kind of a fixed thing because it's
going to fall under
management with the sec and this this is
not managed this is no regulation this
is not regulated as tightly here this is
more of a
some
you know four or five old boys get
together by an apartment complex it's a
little bit past that but not much yeah
you know so uh and and you know one of
the guys is the property manager so he
put the whole deal together that kind of
a thing but that's that's the basis for
the idea
and uh yeah you can make some money in
some of those some of those are
legitimate deals i'm not saying they're
all illegitimate but enough of them are
that they scare me and
getting in and out of a large piece of
real estate is not always something you
can count on it's a long-term play yeah
well it could be that you know let's
pretend that you thought you were going
to flip it in a year because the
market's quite hot and now you are today
in a recession so you are not going to
flip it in here and so you you know now
i can't you know i haven't lost my money
but i really can't get it out it's very
illiquid so anyway interesting play but
only if you got the money to burn that'd
be the only place you do something like
that and i
don't personally do those and i gave you
the reasons why all right janice is with
us in grand rapids hi janice how are you
i'm fine thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um my dad recently passed away and um um
i received some money i'm sorry 92 000
was from selling this home and then i've
got like 57 000 from his life insurance
and i was just wondering what i should
do with the money um i was thinking
about paying off my home but
okay i i
i stepped on you i was trying to say i'm
sorry for you for your loss and i didn't
hear your numbers when did he pass away
um just this past january he had covered
pneumonia oh i'm sorry
okay now again you got 57 000 from one
thing and what was the other figure
um the 92 000 was selling the home so i
know i won't have to pay any taxes on
that money
no you probably won't you're right
that's your basis in it should be
your name was not on the deed prior to
death right
no okay good yeah you've got a
stepped-up basis you shouldn't have any
taxes on that
so
uh you got 150 grand basically
and your question your question then
about what to do with that is whether to
pay off your house what do you owe on
your home
i owe 117.
great do you have any other debt
um i maybe have like 2 000 credit card
debt my car is all paid off
um i have some money in savings how much
do you have in savings
i have about thirteen thousand in
savings okay that's sorry about an
emergency fund
i'm 58 years old how much is in your
retirement accounts
um
i foolishly i had a um
i had a uh
what's that when you have to your work
um 401k
yeah and i went into it because i heard
about this investment and i lost all my
money so i have nothing right now in
retirement
okay so if you pay off your home you're
gonna have to use the old house money
the old house payment money to regain
your retirement and build it back
conservatively
no more games
no more no more high-risk bets right
correct yes yeah if that's what you're
going to do then yeah i would pay off
your height yeah i'd get connected with
a smart investor pro on our website as
well who can help you make some wise
decisions with your future income and
the rest of this money yeah that's
exactly right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage autumn
is with us hey autumn how are you hey
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve where do you live i live in
river falls wisconsin which is outside
of the twin cities yeah great welcome to
nashville thank you and how much debt
did you pay off i paid off 26.5 000 in
13 months all right i love it and uh
what was your range of income over that
year it was 65 to 73. good what do you
do for a living i work in member
communications but i also added serving
and house cleaning to my resume
whatever it took the side hustle girl
way to go i like it good for you which
one paid better uh honestly probably the
house cleaning yeah yeah yeah i bet it
did that's awesome and uh 27 thousand
dollars worth of what kind of debt it
was student loans it was all sally yes
you evicted sally mack
put her on the street you're you're a
cold landlord
you put the old woman out
what was your degree in i was in
business administration and marketing
cool yeah good for you well done how old
are you i'm 28 now all right so what
started this journey uh 13 months ago
yeah so actually i had initially tried
to pay off my debt a couple years ago
and it was going great until i just
found myself completely struggling with
a mental health crisis um so much so
like i couldn't even make it through a
day without work without calling my mom
and crying and um so i decided what the
best thing for me to do is actually quit
my salary job and i went back to working
full-time in a gas station and that just
allowed me the flexibility to be able to
kind of reset and find someone that i
could talk to so i spent eight months at
that gas station just focusing on
getting better
and
i finally landed the job that i have now
and to be honest i kind of drug my feet
a little bit i think i was afraid to
commit to the plan but ultimately i
decided that i needed to finish my
journey and so i totaled up my remaining
debts and the rest is history boom yeah
so you met with somebody and got help
with anxiety or depression or what i was
actually struggling with obsessive
compulsive disorder
okay all right and the gas station just
kind of gave you some
you can kind of keep it in neutral there
you don't have to keep it in gear it was
like i needed to do something different
and so that kind of gave me the freedom
to be able to just reset and you know
not focus on work or anything i could
just not a high stress job yeah right
unless you're getting robbed
it didn't happen so
yeah so do you find a connection between
becoming debt free and it helping with
your the mental health piece yeah
honestly like today i feel like i've
kind of completed two journeys in uh wow
and it's really emotional because um
it's kind of the same principles it was
like baby steps through the mental
health but also the baby steps in the
program and so
you know just standing here today it's
all the sweeter after going through that
amen well most of the best
transformation is incremental so that
would be true with both of these things
you're like a double hero yes yeah you
conquered two things way to go it's a
whole new autumn standing in front of us
that's awesome and i love peace yeah i
was gonna say how does it feel it feels
amazing yeah wow really proud of the
person i've become through this process
you should be you should be we're proud
of you thank you well done who are your
biggest cheerleaders uh my wonderful
family
i shouldn't look she's crying um
i i just want to say that
my parents have been with me through the
best and the worst and i could not be
here today without them so
i'm very thankful for all their support
that's very cool very cool good
good and they're going yes you can you
can win both of these battles you can
yes it's doable and you did win both of
them yeah autumn i'm just curious why
didn't you just wait for
the white house to forgive your student
loans you went through all this work i
know well i listened to dave and dave
was like you know what it's probably not
going to happen and so i'm like you know
what i'm not putting off for tomorrow
what i can get done today and so i don't
want to you know spend my life just
waiting in limbo so
i don't have any regrets with doing it
now for age yeah that's good
well you take control of your own life
there is uh something about that because
that way you take control of your own
life
it's amazing how that works yeah well
done well done what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is
honestly you've got to have your i've
had it moment where you just decide
where you're all in
i think for me i was just afraid to have
that moment but i realized that what i
was more afraid of was actually waking
up five years down the road and
wondering what would have happened had i
just started that day that was kind of
the motivation that i needed to just get
it done yeah
yeah when you uh when you go go all in
the fear is if what if this doesn't work
yeah yeah that's scary that's the scary
part of it and and with what you were
facing on the other front that's a
double scary yeah yeah so very cool very
cool sounds like you had some good help
yeah i did yeah
now very good good for you good for you
well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that definitely is
the next chapter in your story without a
doubt that's where you're headed and uh
copy of a total money makeover you'll be
able to give that to someone who's
inspired by your story at least the
money piece of your story
so uh we probably got a john de loni
book that'll help you with the other
part yeah that'd be good yeah
and uh we'll give you also a one-year uh
membership to financial peace university
it's got the new videos in it with
george campbell and rachel cruz dr john
deloney and me best best we've ever done
on fpu it's good stuff so be sure you go
through that if you haven't if not give
it to somebody so either way it's all
just for you to say thank you for making
the trip here and we're very proud of
you thank you i know your mom and dad
are and your friends are and your
therapist everybody's cheering you on
you
you're you're a fun person an easy
person to cheer on well done hero very
very well done
all right it's autumn river falls
wisconsin 27 000
paid off in 13 months making 65 to 73.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one i'm dead free
[Applause]
way to go autumn yeah
that was visceral
good stuff
i'm uh
been doing this for 30 years and i never
cease to be impressed with
how the old saying discipline begets
discipline healing
in one area of your life begets healing
in another area of your life yeah how
many times do we hear an overlap
of someone lost a bunch of weight while
they're getting out of debt someone's
marriage was healed
while they were healing their finances
uh and and in her case she is walking a
mental health
uh path
transformational path
and um
and then simultaneously somewhat of an
overlap not 100 simultaneous but is
overlapping this other area of healing
at the same time
there is something i i think what
happens is our confidence
once we go well if i can do that maybe i
can do that and if i can do that maybe i
could do that there's a feeling of i can
rise above where i'm at right now it
gives you power once you have some
incremental progress that's why the baby
steps that's why the debt snowball works
you pay off the little one you go whoa
paid off the little maybe i can get the
next one and you know it builds your
hope
hope is a powerful elixir yeah we talk
about focus intensity over time
multiplied by god equals unstoppable
momentum
focus intensity is what the baby steps
are and it's what it takes to improve
your marriage it's what it takes to
overcome addictions and we see that time
and time again on the debt-free stage
where they go dave it changed my
marriage i don't even realize it dave i
overcame addiction while getting out of
debt because i was just so focused on
this thing over here and it's amazing
the transformation that happens across
every area of life yeah the number of
times we deal with someone
who
as a part of their addiction recovery
decide to clean up their money
or decide to clean up their money and
let them do addiction recovery
or
mental health challenges or relational
challenges or career changes
uh this idea that there's something
about once you decide i am in control of
more than i
was thinking
and now that i see that i'm in control
of that well i'm probably more in
control of this other thing and i'm
going to go over here and i'm going to
do that and so she you know she didn't
adopt the victim status of i'm going to
wait on joe biden to pay off my student
loans she said i want my life back
i want sally mae out of my life well the
threat is you have agency over your life
that's it and until you believe that
your life isn't going to change because
you're going to continue to have things
happen to you instead of you happening
to it
that's a big paradigm shift for a lot of
people to make
but it's life-changing once you make it
agency that's a good word agent it's an
old-timey word dave i thought you'd
enjoy that you need an agent you need a
new agent
you you're the new agent
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five craig's in
jacksonville florida hi craig how are
you
good sir how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
doing good and it's a very it's an honor
to finally meet you and sorry i'm just a
little nervous um how can we help
i had a quick question um i was trying
to figure out i guess how i would stay
motivated during the baby step two um
i've been listening to you for about a
year through all your youtube videos and
podcasts and i actually i was
listening to some of the videos where i
called you today and that's what
encouraged me to call um
i'm currently again working on baby step
two i've probably paid about thirty five
thousand out of the six thousand dollars
in debt so far way to go and
i'm just kind of hitting a
an emotional
like mental and motivation
speed bump in this process
why do you think that is
well i just have a bunch of stuff on my
mind on what the career path i have um
family issues going on my health and
everything so things have just kind of
taken a toll
over this whole year of grinding out
through this debt paying journey that
i'm one what's wrong with your health
well well i have congestive heart
failures um since i've been since i was
26 i'm 30 years old now so that that
that did not change
no no sir okay what's wrong with your
family
um my mother and father actually
have split up and now kind of
reworking their relationship so that's
kind of a cause too on everything
because i actually
stay with family member because of the
health issue i have
so you stay with one of them
i i stay at my uh grandmother's house
she bought the house when my when we
moved here in florida and i've been
staying there so your parents are not in
your
in your space every day
but they're they're going through their
own crap right
they are and my father tends to
use me as a crutch while i'm going
through what i'm going through and
sometimes it's very hard
yeah
okay and then you said you have a career
path issue
yes i'm currently a manager at a local
walgreens i work with i make about 31
000 a year
and
i'm blessed to have a job because i was
working at a different job before coving
and then i switched back to this job so
and i'm just kind of not
really happy where i'm at because of the
amount i make
and it has got me through the first year
of me paying my
debt that i have but i've just kind of
felt like a slow
you know slowly my motivation starting
to hit rock bottom that makes sense
yeah because here's what's happening you
feel like this job's happening to you
you're not happening to it you feel like
your parents mess is happening to you
you're not happening to it and the heart
thing is happening to you and obviously
you can't happen to it
you don't get to control that one
uh but these these things are
controlling you
because you're allowing them to
yes sir
the parents mess
um
and your job mess
so you have the here's the thing it's
hard to have a sense of power over your
money when you have a sense of
powerlessness
in key relationships and powerlessness
in your career
yes sir they they it's you know because
it's sucking what confidence you're you
gain a little confidence over here in
the money thing
like you paid off 35 000 that's really
good
but then it gets sick it's like your dad
and mom come along with a confidence uh
syringe and remove it
craig how long did it take to pay off
the 35
um i actually started last july and
that's including working at my job with
overtime and side gigs here and there
dude you've been living off nothing
that's impressive yeah i've literally
every two weeks i literally live off 150
and beans and rice rice and beans
literally wow
well on the health side that's something
you've got to manage that's obviously
not something we can just fix overnight
on the parent side it may require a
boundary with dad and a hard
conversation say dad listen
you need to find a good therapist a
counselor who can help walk you through
this i can't be that for you and on the
career side you can go be a manager
somewhere else you can start applying
today and probably make way more than
31.
yes sir
and so if you have that pep in your step
going i'm in control i can do this and
worst case you're doing this for one
year longer why'd you start the baby
steps to begin with
because
i wanted that financial freedom i
remember not having any debt having
money in the bank
um
you know able to buy something i wanted
not go you know take like a car payment
or anything out but just having that
financial freedom and not that burden
you know you know what the problem with
a free book is
nobody reads them
because they were free nobody paid for
you didn't pay for it but i'm gonna give
you two free books anyway on the risk
that i can get you to read them
i'm gonna give you paycheck to purpose
by ken coleman
so you get up on top of this career
thing and you start happening to it
instead of it happening to you and i'm
going to give you own your past change
your future
from dr john dolone so you can begin to
have some tools
to work with mom and dad and say i love
you
but i can't fix this
i'm actually the kid
you're actually the parent
i can't fix this
and so
uh only the strong can help the weak and
you are not strong enough to carry your
dad right now
so him being uh using you as a crutch
he's got a rubber crutch he's going to
hit the floor
so uh and you're both going down
so you you know you've got to love him
uh but not be carrying around his stuff
you're carrying around all of his
burdens instead of him carrying them
and you feel stuck over at the job
because you haven't done anything about
getting unstuck
so i'm gonna give you both books and uh
they're two different things but this
all comes back to
craig you taking power you're taking uh
george's word agency over your life in
these areas and uh when you do you're
gonna get some energy back for getting
out of debt but right now you got these
two three
negative drains pulling you down while
you've got one area you're being
successful in that is very difficult for
anyone my man
well dave i'm gonna add in one more gift
in case he gets sick of reading craig
i'm gonna send you financial peace
university you can watch those videos it
also will include every dollar the
premium version so you can make a plan
for every dollar coming in and attack
this debt faster because i don't want
you to have to sacrifice longer than you
have yeah you know that's good and
getting try to find one of the financial
peace groups in your area
get connected and really let's get some
human beings in the room with you
who are excited that showed up
that'll hold you accountable they're not
going to put up a whining but they also
in the other side are going to love you
and just say hey man you know you can do
this they'll incur encouragement
accountability we all need in areas
where we're struggling so yeah we'll
plug into all of that so dude we're
going to load you up with resources
uh because it's it's easy to
to uh
have this many things coming at you
that are stealing power in so many
different areas it's easy to feel
powerless
the interesting thing is you're not
that you can just decide today i'm not
carrying my father's stuff around he
gets to carry his own stuff
i can apply for him i love him and i
know he's hurting but i can't fix all
that i'm going to let him carry his own
deal
and here's his backpack and i don't want
to be it just uh
just you know oh yeah there's walgreens
john
john talks about that all the time the
bricks in the backpack that we carry
around from other people putting them in
there yep and we're wondering why we
can't even crawl yeah that's exactly
what it is yeah exactly what's going on
here so yeah you can do this man you
really can and if you need some more
help you call back anytime we're here to
talk to you and give ken coleman a call
on his show yeah be a fun one yeah on
the career side yeah um
we'll always tell you the truth but um i
i just kind of hear it and
um you know when you don't have uh when
you don't physically feel great because
of the heart thing going on it makes it
triple hard to fight through the other
stuff
so it's a mental exercise of tough
mental toughness for you to move through
these other areas controlling the things
you can control
and then things start to move for you
and let go of the rest that's exactly it
hey thank you for calling sir hang on
we'll get you all those materials out to
you and try to help you any way we can
that about puts this particular hour in
the books our thanks to austin ben zack
andrew and james and kelly in the booth
i am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status of full of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and the entree
leadership podcast is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
lauren is in atlanta starting off this
hour hi lauren how are you
i'm doing okay how are you doing dave
better than we deserve how can we help
um well i will try to keep this short
my husband and i are currently upside
down in the house that we're in and the
mortgage is in my name and i'm just
uh desperate to find options besides
bankruptcy but uh wondering if you think
i i should just go ahead and file
bankruptcy
are you behind
no sir um the house how much is your
payment
it is 750
um
what do you owe on the house
115
okay and what is what do you think it's
worth
well that's the thing um so back in 2008
um
i put a lot of money in the house
because my grandmother insisted on
staying there
um until she passed that was always what
her goal was and so
the house was very under you know in bad
shape then
but just wanted to honor her so put um
had a friend that helped me kind of put
work into the house i was
unaware that the work that was being
done wasn't done properly
for instance they put a new kitchen on a
rotted subfloor
the cells in the house are rotted
there's wood-eating fungus that's
destroyed
the base of the house
it's just the house is sick we had to
move out about a year and a half ago
for our health we were losing our hair
and
our dog was getting sick as well and
so we've been paying rent and paying the
mortgage um
thinking that we
you know we could just kind of be have
you had anybody look at it to tell you
what it's worth in the crummy condition
that it's in so
it's worthless um
we've been told not another diamond to
it
stop stop stop with the drama
have you had anybody that's a
professional real estate person or
investor look at it and tell you what
it's worth
we've had several people um and they say
it's worth zero
no well forty thousand is what the land
is worth um
so that's what i mean we're upside down
i don't mean to be dramatic it's kind of
well it's not you said it's worthless
that was dramatic it is not working it's
worth 40 000 bucks okay
so it's
worth anything sir but the land is worth
40 000. how much land is involved
5.8 acres where
in atlanta um it's actually outside of
uh outside atlanta uh closest big city i
would say is atlanta um but athens
outside of athens georgia
so a rural community
yes sir okay
do you have homeowners insurance
i do um and back in 2015 i tried to
contact them to see if they would help
with the mold i had some of the mold
remediated
and it worked temporarily
but
it's uh
who do you owe the money to
um the mortgage company currently is
regions
is it an fha loan a va loan or a
conventional loan
i believe it is a conventional but i'm
not 100
okay and what is your household income
uh my husband and i make around
30 000
currently um okay
you are not bankrupt
but you are in a mess you already knew
that yes i already knew that okay yes
sir so worst case scenario is
you get foreclosed on
because you quit paying payments on this
today
and um
worst case is uh okay
the uh
i would go ahead and contact regions
and say i'm done
the house is falling in i can't fix it i
only make 30 000 a year put me in touch
with your short sale department
okay get in touch with a real estate
agent at ramseysolutions.com
and interview some of our elps our
endorsed local providers ask them when
you're interviewing them if they have
any experience with a short sale
okay very few short sales in today's
world but you have a house that has
rotted down and lost its value and
you've got basic structural thing it
just needs a stick of dynamite thrown in
it i hear you it's over yes sir it
wasn't a great house to start with and
then it's gotten worse
and so
here's what's going to happen let's
pretend that 40 000 is a real number i'm
not positive it is
that means this land is worth less than
ten thousand dollars an acre i
suspect you probably get more than that
for it it's in a flood plain i i forgot
to tell you that the whole thing
railroad the railroad expanded well the
d.o.t expanded the highway in front of
the house years ago we have to the whole
five acres is in a flood plain no no
sure okay
flooding under there for for many years
that's okay the house is gone
so here's what's gonna happen
the real estate agent gets you an offer
of forty or fifty thousand dollars but
you owe
what you say 150 115 115 115 then that
offer goes to regions and regions can
decide if they want to accept that
okay
and if they accept that offer
then they forgive the rest of the loan
now here's the word you must remember
the phrase you must remember
this is a short sale without recourse
without recourse which means they can't
come back after you for the difference
in the 115 and the 50 grand you get for
it
okay but if they get 10 000 bucks an
acre out of this that'd be 50 grand
and they take that offer to regions
regents says hey look after we foreclose
on
and we take this property back we're not
going to get 115 for it we're going to
get 50 for it then we've got to go sue
this woman named lauren who makes thirty
thousand dollars a year at which point
she'll file chapter seven bankruptcy and
we're gonna get nothing so we're just
gonna take this
okay that's what a short sale is that's
how the logic works but you've gotta
have an agent that knows how to make
that pitch
two regions and work through the
region's
mess
and regions is no picnic to work with
they're a pain in the butt
but maybe
they just are it's a stupid bank so
um but you know here's the thing
quit paying payments
a b number two get a real estate agent
that'll help you with a short sale you
can do that at ramseysolutions.com
and then um see
hopefully we can get them to accept an
offer from an investor or a local guy
who wants to just farm it and push the
house down or whatever right maybe your
next door neighbor wants the property um
and they'll accept it without recourse
okay
that way they don't chase you for the
difference kiddo
but this is gonna be a it's gonna take
six months to a year of your life of
screwing with this but all that time
you're gonna be saving 750 bucks a month
because you ain't paying any more
payments if they do come around and
foreclose and come after you you can
deal with it then settle with them on
that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five okay
one of the things you're supposed to do
when you listen to this show is be
entertained and you can't help but do
that
uh because people are just plain
entertaining
uh especially george and i think you're
talking about the callers yeah well i
was but i was also talking about that
you're just just amazing talent but the
uh thank you uh
the other thing you're supposed to do is
you're supposed to learn
and so there are you know you know we
have these things called mentors
and a lot of our callers are
anti-mentors i think you're gonna say
dementors which is different well it's
yeah there's they're they're
anti-mentors you don't do what they did
now so you learn from that last caller
okay what did what was the whole thing
that set this whole thing up
what went wrong grandma wanted her to
put
50 to 75 000
more
into a rotted down house
than it was worth
in order to be happy in her last days
now
this is the point where you look at
granny and you use the magic word
is it no
yes no is the magic word no granny i'll
be happy to take care of you i love you
uh me going bankrupt
is not an act of love towards you
[Laughter]
right you would have been better off
getting her an apartment somewhere yeah
yeah i mean for what they spent in pain
trouble
and mess but it was an old family place
it's probably granny's old place
and there's a lot of emotion
and uh
you can just get caught up in the
family drama
and get into stupidville
real quick
instead you've got to back up pan back
and look at this and go wait a minute
this is a bad idea
now i love my grandmother
i there's no question you should love
your grandmother
some of your grandmothers aren't lovable
but you should love them anyway and
that's not a that's not a question but
the
but but that you know you still have to
have wisdom about how you go about this
and
um
we don't bankrupt ourselves for grandma
it's
well for grandma's
wishes which are ridiculous
especially
okay now if we could save her life
by paying for her cancer treatments yeah
okay that's different i'll go there you
know you do whatever you gotta do there
but you know
grandma wants a better house
and that's how she's gonna be happy in
her last days uh you should have thought
of that 50 years ago when you didn't
save money granny uh because i can't do
this and i'm not dropping a bunch of
money and this house is rotten down
because that's obviously was a piece of
crap house before this whole story
started
um probably should have been pushed down
in 2008 instead of fixed up
it sounds like sound like it's a mess
and so um
instead we renovated a kitchen on top of
a rotting house right underneath there's
just there's a lot so you know it's not
the pick on the poor girl that called in
i mean bless her out she's got a mess
we're here to help her everybody's done
something stupid and that's hers okay
i've done plenty of more more stupid
things than that things that were more
stupid than that or however you say that
both really but
but
but yeah so always be listening to these
calls and learning from them that's a
that's a deal
so um
and the advice was
shoot for the short sale is her best bet
yeah yeah the one thing i didn't think
of until we got off the air at the break
is
i still i mean i i thought maybe that
was old family farm and maybe it's in
granny's name and if that mortgage was
in granny's name which i doubt it was
because she said she had to go get the
fix up but if that mortgage isn't
granny's name and granny died and the
farm is in granny's name and granny died
i'll just call regents and tell him
here's the keys
good luck with this
i mean just give it to them because who
are they foreclosing on the the estate
and you know there's nothing here it's a
negative the estate has a negative net
worth
so they get they get nothing for making
this loan which oh by the way how do
they make this loan
that's what i was wondering how did this
thing even appraise for finance it
didn't
it didn't so bogus horrible lending
practice here
so um and so a little bit a little bit
there on regions but they're gonna get
they're gonna get to pay for it so it's
okay it's gonna work out
uh blake is in atlanta hi blake how are
you
i'm good guys how are y'all better than
we deserve man what's up
all right uh my wife and i always sold
our house a year and a half ago and we
we our kind of long-term goal was to
have as much acreage as we could and
build a house and you know live the
dream yada yada so
we purchased
with the profit that we made on our
house we purchased 26.5 acres in uh
darresville georgia and we are we were
looking to build there and that was the
plan um
we've got the land cleaned up it's uh it
was really grown up and now it's not
that looks good and we're ready to build
on it but these interest rates just kind
of went through the roof and just kind
of pushed us outside of where we were
comfortable building
um
in regards to what the what the monthly
payment was going to be
conservatively speaking so
now we've got the land on the market or
can we kind of step back and and feel
like the best decision for us is to be
able to sell the land
and then take the profit that we make
from that and then just purchase a home
okay um
outright is what we're
what we're thinking uh that kind of
where we were on the fence is kind of
just
i guess
putting the dream on pause for a minute
i don't know if you know over time the
the land's probably going to be more
expensive if we try to go do this again
but on the flip side we're thinking
about just our lifestyle in general and
it being just having the freedom of not
having a mortgage being 33 and
and going that route what would be your
advice on should we how much would the
payment be with the new interest rates
2500
what's your take on pay
we we made 123 000 last year sell the
land
yeah
i i figured i kind of served you a beach
ball on this one
so you're saying you could sell the land
and buy a home with cash a beach ball
with a very low net yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah so that's kind of what we're
thinking man you know i just
thought for us to be to be and my wife's
not she's in her 20s and i'm 33 so for
us to
do that buy a house not have a mortgage
and then well that part that part's
really cool and i like that part i mean
if you told me your payment was gonna be
a thousand dollars and you're just
you're just freaking out over nothing i
tell you to build the house
but your payment ratio is off
yeah when it was in the four percent
range we were we were still high
yeah yeah
because we tell you what you know what
we tell you right 25 of your take-home
pay
your take home pays what 660 hundred
seven thousand dollars
yeah something like that yeah yeah
that's tough a fourth of that is what we
would tell you on a 15-year fix you
probably heard us say that right
i have yeah you weren't making that on a
four percent loan either
no no i wasn't yeah so i'm glad you
didn't call me back then because i would
have burst your bubble earlier
right how long ago did you buy this land
blake
we've had it a year and a half and and
thankfully just the way the market's
been it's we bought it at 4 500 acre and
we've got it for sale right now for 15
an acre
we dropped it today actually to the 15
from eighteen and acre and everything
surrounding that is that's what that's
what that's what it's selling for yeah
good i'm so worried
well you're gonna make some money and
life is good and you move on to the next
deal and like you said you're gonna be
having a very peaceful life in a paid
for house and you save up and you'll do
your land deal later
and uh you know sometimes sharon and i
when we're looking at deals um we did
this the other day we're actually
looking at a piece of ground the other
day
and um
we both neither one of us could get real
comfortable with it so we kind of just
think yeah
this is like not so fun it's okay but
it's not like
it's not it's not a spike you're not
excited about it it's okay but it's not
you know and when we do that sometimes
because we've lived in nashville for 40
years to get i mean been married 40
years and lived in nashville right so
and i grew up in nashville so sometimes
we'll just go driving around and look at
all the deals we didn't do remember when
we almost bought that aren't you glad we
didn't remember we almost bought that
aren't you glad we did it it's called
remember when we sold that aren't you
glad we did yes
and we've done enough deals that we can
do that for a couple hours and then we
just go home and go we're not doing it i
love that that's called jomo dave the
joy of missing out
oh dodge that bullet dodge that bullet
jomo the joy of missing out a george
campbell original
maybe this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage shannon
is with us hey shannon how are you hi
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve where are you where do you live
i'm from houston texas all right good
texas girl awesome how much debt did you
pay off i paid off 204 thousand dollars
awesomeness how long did this take it
took me about 45 months or three years
nine months got it and your range of
income during that time i started out at
104 and i ended up one around 120. cool
what do you do for a living i'm a
physician assistant oh good pa
that's the 204 student loan debt yeah
yeah was it most of a student loan or
all that it was mainly student loan and
then a car fleece ah okay cool very cool
so almost four years yes you've been
chugging at this yes how long have you
been out of school
about that same amount of time about
four years so you got out of school and
you said i'm gonna attack this how did
you get connected to this ramsay stuff
and how did you decide to do it i know i
was trying to think about that i'm over
here i think i just got out of school
and i knew i had this mountain to
to get over and i think i just started
googling getting out of debt and i think
i just found you and everything worked
out and there it is good old google and
you just went with it you were just like
all right sounds good yeah yeah it took
me a while to really get
gazelle intense at first i wanted to
start my 401k and get going with the
future and i just realized i wasn't
making enough traction and so i just
went
dove right in and wow game took right
off yep okay so you found us on google
and then
and then i've just been going kind of
gung-ho i mean i've read all the books i
listened to the podcast every day and
just kind of and i did fpu too oh wow
wow okay you did go all in i did yep so
financial peace university read the
books and podcasts all started from a
simple i went out of debt search yeah
good for you yep good for you well one
thing about being a pa that's a tough
line of study and i took a lot of
discipline
and some sacrifice to hit a goal it did
and so when you say oh there's a goal oh
i know how to do that discipline and
sacrifice right so it's not you you know
how to delay pleasure you've already
done that right to get this degree to be
able to be in this field right right
yeah and you come out of school and you
and you want to live on your nice
paycheck and but i just put my head down
and i did it so i don't have to do it
ever again i love that did your pa
friends think you're weird they're like
you're doing great why didn't you pay
off this debt so quickly they were all
really supportive they're all doing
their own things and they were they were
proud of me for doing it so well that's
good maybe you'll inspire them they go
wait you did it 45 months tell me more
exactly i hope so that's awesome how's
it feel to be free
it feels so good i know people say this
but it really does feel like a weight is
lifted off your shoulders it's just
you're free of this burden you know you
just don't have to worry about it
anymore you can just get on with your
life and not worry about what you did
when you were 18.
do you remember what the payment was on
that 204 thousand the most it got up to
and i've heard another girl say this on
her screen the most it got up to was
like
when i did extra it was like five
thousand dollars a month and i remember
somebody saying that that was like a
luxury vacation they were paying off
every month and i just had that fun way
to look at it i was like i just want a
luxury vacation at the end of all this
so so are you gonna take one what are
you doing uh well this is our start this
is the start and then we'll we'll do one
in a year or two yeah well nashville is
a nice place to visit yeah yeah
luxury it's the job done right yeah
that's awesome yeah it's not italy but
it'll work right all right good for you
well done thank you well done
so now you've done it um
you're a person who sets goals and
knocks them down
uh the latest one is 204 thousand
dollars in 45 months
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
the key to getting out of debt everybody
says the budget i totally agree it's
it's the budget i love the every dollar
budget app um and then just getting
really gazelle intense i just at the
beginning i just had all my
uh i just want to do my 401k and i
wanted to save up for an emergency fund
and i wanted to do my student loans and
i just wasn't making any traction and so
just putting all your eggs in one basket
just going all in and then just putting
your head down and it's done the power
focus yeah yeah just zero in if you have
to do one thing because nothing gets
done if you don't do the one thing first
right yeah it feels like wisdom to try
to do a little bit of everything right
but then you wonder why you're in the
same place you were a year ago yes
you're not seeing the numbers move we
need that as part of our psyche as
humans absolutely you've experienced it
yeah it's awesome yeah good job thanks
thank you who was cheering you on i had
lots of cheerleaders one of them was my
boyfriend nick he bought me fpu he go
you go i like nick um and he actually
paid off his debt alongside me as well
so that was really helpful good
motivation and then my parents and i
asked them to be here today they
couldn't make it with us but they were
really big cheerleaders along the way
too and then my best girlfriends rebecca
and jennifer they're financial uh
finance nerds kind of like me and we
would just kind of text back and forth
about all the tips and i would text them
with my milestones and they were both
really encouraging so it was really
helpful
very good there's a theme today other
people
matter in your financial journey don't
do it alone absolutely accountability
and encouragement it's really important
yeah you're amazing thank you well done
thank you very well done she already
knew that
try
good stuff we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure you are on your way how
extraordinary people built
or how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
uh we'll give you another copy of
financial peace membership you can give
that away to somebody
since you've been through the class and
also a copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to somebody uh since
you and nick are in the business of
encouraging people and getting them
moving in the right direction good stuff
very good stuff and thank you for
trusting us on the journey yeah
for being here we're honored to have uh
been cheering you on uh even though we
didn't know it until today so uh we're
proud of you very very very well done
thank you all right shannon in houston
texas
204 thousand dollars of sally may pa
loan
done in 45 months making 104 to 120
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream all right three two one i'm debt
free
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that's amazing
absolutely amazing very very well done
very well done well we've got uh
we're coming into a political season
with the midterms coming up
and um
you're going to hear the volume come up
watch the volume click click
click
on student loans
and how out of control they are
and what an epic failure the whole
system is
completely agree with all of that
and so it must be that we forgive the
loans
and so there's going to be some
uh
politics played
it's a nice way to put it where they uh
act like they're doing something and
they're not that's what politics played
is
about forgiving the loans but there's
going to be a lot of discussion and a
lot of rancor in the air again and a lot
of
carrying on about how stuck people are
and that they can't move on with their
lives and millennials are putting off
having children or the careers that they
want and
all because of their student loan debt
and enter
our last debt free screen
who says
don't think so no thanks i'll do it
myself no thanks
i'll take 45 months and i will pay back
the 204 000 that i borrowed to go to
school
and um i will have the dignity of having
done that
i did sign the paper that said i owed it
and i'm not waiting on the white house
to fix my house i'm going to do this you
just
keep this in mind
when you hear this volume knob start
clicking up
because it's just a matter of well just
a matter of a couple three four weeks
we're gonna start hearing it
and it's gonna get louder and louder and
louder and louder until we get to
october and then it'll just get real
quiet again
it happens every year but if in over
time it's been happening more and more
because the crisis is finally getting
you know it's getting out there people
are this is not a secret anymore but
there i mean there's two messages we
want everybody to get from this don't
get in student loan debt and if you did
you can get out
yeah and we'll show you how and the
politicians will help you they're
they're half right in presenting the
problem but the solution to them is vote
for me i'm gonna be the savior on the
white horse but instead you gotta look
in the mirror and go
no the politicians i'll talk no shock
there i'm gonna do this thing
the white horse is a hand puppet
so i'm just saying
it's not working
remember that left-handed puppetry
got the degree in left-handed puppetry
then they went into politics
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day colossians 3
9-10 don't lie to each other for
you have stripped off your old sinful
nature and all its wicked deeds put on
your new nature and be renewed as you
learn to know your creator and become
like him
mark twain said if you tell the truth
you don't have to remember anything
that's another way to put it there you
go he was like tweeting before tweeting
was a thing just short snappy witty
no question about it with rising costs
everywhere you look we know you've had
enough right now normal in america is
getting freaked out by the total on the
cash register in the grocery store
asking the cashier to take stuff off
like a gallon of milk so you don't
overdraft your bank account well normal
sucks you deserve a chance at some extra
breathing room we're super excited to
tell you this month we're giving away
five hundred dollars cash every week and
a grand prize of three thousand dollars
in our ramsey cash giveaway
you can enter every day there is of
course no purchase necessary and you
must be 18 to win ramsay solutions dot
com
slash giveaway
every day
enter
ramseysolutions.com
slash
giveaway
so
we had a
uh our our business has been open now
for
30 years
i've been on the air for 30 years
um we currently have about 1200 folks
working on our team
and uh over the years folks that have
come and
left and got married left and
you know had a baby went home
or uh took another job or got fired or
whatever we probably got another 1500 or
so
over that 30 years that don't work here
anymore
and
over the years of running a business
that size and growing business and so
forth we've had team members
go through tragedies with the loss of
children
spouses
certainly
grandparents and parents all kinds of
things like that over the years we've
our family we've walked together through
all that um but we have had a uh
a new experience uh this weekend
trying to get through this not cry um
a young man named michael pretorius has
been with us for five years
and
two of the five years that he's
been on our payroll
he uh
was not at work because he's been
fighting cancer and
he
graduated and went to be with jesus on
uh last night
and so first time in our history we've
had an active
team member
pass away
and so our whole place is kind of uh
we've all been walking with him and his
wife and his family and his mom his
sister works here
um and uh
through the whole process and and
you know just watching
the horrible thing that cancer is
and um it's um
i'm stammering because i'm about to cry
but uh it's painful yeah and uh uh
uh
but it's real
and uh
just
an incredible young man oh yeah
incredible his faith during this journey
was one of the most inspiring things to
watch as he fought and i just i was
reading a text from him i got the other
day as i was letting him know we're
praying for him i mean he's in one of
our social groups he's been a good
friend of mine we've you know bunked
together on some of the trips we've done
as guys and
man that guy is a warrior and uh he
loved jesus more than anyone i know yeah
yeah he's a stud
and um
so our hearts are heavy um been a somber
day here and yeah for and certainly for
his wife amanda and
um
you know
rest assured uh
he's got 1200 family members that are
all around him making sure
making around her making sure she's okay
as best she can be through this whole
process but
um there's been a lot of tears in our
building today and um
will continue to be in the weeks to come
i'm sure but um
yeah so if you want something to pray
for today that give you something to
pray for
and um
uh you don't
there there's uh
no amount of preparation you can do for
something like this yeah you can't you
can't get ready
for that
other than making sure you have a good
strong spiritual walk with the lord
and um but
and he did he's an incredible incredible
young guy 29 years old
just uh
just amazing just amazing all right open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
rose is with us rose is in pennsylvania
hi rose how are you
i have post polio syndrome and
fibromyalgia oh that's how i am wow
yeah you got a lot you're dealing with
pardon i said you got a lot you're
dealing with yes
so how can we help today
okay
i have approximately 150 000
saved it's in cds and
money market and
just savings account
and that is all i have
and i would like to know how i can
invest it
wisely and have something to live off
okay well i call uh cds in a situation
like this certificates of depreciation
because you're making nothing girl
as you noticed right you're making
nothing on them not paying anything
anyway yeah you're not making nothing
off this money it's just sitting there
right
and so uh if you made 10 on it it'd be
15 000 bucks
you know 1200 bucks a month coming in
something like that uh and you're making
nothing so that that's years ago the
interest rates were up to yeah they were
but they're not now and they haven't
been they haven't been in in recent
decades okay that's a couple of decades
back that you're talking about so
yeah what i would tell you is this i i
would
personally
invest i do personally invest george
personally invests in good growth stock
mutual funds
with long track records
um
what you have with your
uh by the fact that you're invested in
by the fact you got this money parked in
cds number one and number two you're
fighting all of these uh medical things
uh both of those things tell me you are
really really really anti-risk
and you probably would see mutual funds
is really scary
um they're no more scary than buying a
house
they've got as good a solid a track
record if you buy a house you're gonna
make some money if you hold it a while
um you know it's only been one time in
history in the last 70 years that 80
years almost 100 years that house prices
have gone down and that was 2008
one time
now mutual funds are more volatile than
that they go up and down but
i would sit down with a smart vester pro
and i would not do
what the smart vester pro says
and i would not do what dave ramsey or
george campbell says i would learn
about mutual funds and then you do what
you
decide to do
that way you won't wake up in the middle
of the night freaked out scared because
you will understand that'll make you
understand and be comfortable with
before you move forward
that this when you meet with an
investment professional as a heart of a
teacher it changes everything yeah
they're not going to sit there and go
well here here's all the things we're
going to do they'll recommend things and
they'll help you understand why they're
recommending what they're recommending
but it's up to you to actually make the
call
and so we get calls sometimes they go
well they made me do no they didn't make
you do anything
yeah my financial advisor lost money for
me no you lost money for you you took
their advice so you're they're called an
advisor not a teller what to do that
would be a terrible name anyways yeah
that's a horrible name so well yeah
that's good didn't even work when i was
saying it but yeah tell her what to do
so for long-term mutual funds for
short-term now i don't think she needs
this money today clearly it's locked up
in a cd anyways yeah it it needs to be
making some money that's why she called
so yeah you need to learn about the
mutual funds and buy
super conservative that don't have the
volatility because you're going to be
it's going to scare you to death when
you first do it and don't even move all
the money at once in there move just 50
000 and then kind of get comfortable
with that and it's like kind of wading
into the water you get used to the water
up your knees and you get used to the
water and then you can kind of get out
and then you can just go on in you know
but you don't have to just dive in god
it's cold that's what crypto is dave
that's the polar ice plunge you throw
your money in crypto
no polar raj plunge is good for you
that's true good caveat
bad metaphor
so sit down go to ramseysolutions.com
hon and sit down with a smart investor
pro and let them guide you and teach you
and you learn and if you know what's
going on you'll have peace with the
investing
that puts us however the ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you